buongiorno a tutti e grazie
sono qui a portare l'esperienza di un
piccolo territorio di una scheggia di
roccia che però è posta al centro del
mediterraneo si chiama lampedusa estesa
20 chilometri quadrati e ha una
popolazione di 5.800 abitanti però in
dal 1991 ad oggi ha salvato la vita e
accolto più di 300.000 persone dico che
io sono il sindaco di un'isola che
sembra piccola ma che in realtà ho fatto
qualcosa di così grande perché ci sono
300mila lampedusani che sono andati in
giro per il mondo grazie a questa
scheggia posta al centro del
mediterraneo come isola di transizione
tra due continenti così è avvenuto in
questi anni si sono chiuse le rotte
migratorie che partivano dalla tunisia e
dal marocco e che portavano in sicilia
soprattutto migranti magrebini si è
aperta la rotta
che attraversa il deserto della libia
sarà e arriva in libia per affrontare
poi il mare ed è questo il popolo in
cammino del dei paesi del corno d'africa
del sud sarà sono eritrei somali
soprattutto per 20 anni sono stati
soprattutto i tre somali
ora negli ultimi anni si sono aggiunti
anche siriani afghani iracheni e sempre
di più
assistiamo a una variazione arrivano
anche dal ghana dal mali dalla costa
d'avorio
perché la situazione in questi paesi
diventa sempre più grave è quello che
dobbiamo imparare che non sono i
soccorsi in mare che incentivano le
partenze dalla libia
una lezione che a lampedusa abbiamo
fatto oltre quella di vedere in faccia
queste persone io dico lampedusa non ha
fatto nulla di straordinario
quasi quasi sono felice che non ci
abbiano dato il nobel
bisognerebbe semmai dare un premio
attila chi non fa le cose che i
lampedusani hanno fatto
noi abbiamo avuto il privilegio di
guardare in faccia queste persone di
vedere dove di scendere dai barconi
quando c'è un poeta che dice con la
saggezza dei poeti
nessun padre metterebbe il proprio
figlio su quei barconi
se non ritenesse il mare più sicuro
della terra ecco questa è una verità che
i lampedusani hanno visto negli anni con
i loro occhi
abbiamo visto arrivare famiglie che
erano partiti in sei e sono arrivati in
tre perché i tre figli sono caduto non
morti in mare ma caduti dai camion che
li trasportano lungo il deserto
il viaggio sui barconi e solo la parte
terminale di una di un viaggio tremendo
organizzato e gestito dalla criminalità
da un'organizzazione criminale molto
diffusa molto diffusa nei paesi africani
ma presente è dislocata anche nei paesi
europei
queste verità sono emerse dal press dal
processo che ha portato alla condanna a
30 anni di uno degli organizzatori del
viaggio che si è trasformato in una
delle più grandi tragedie del
mediterraneo il naufragio del 3 ottobre
2013 a lampedusa
ricorre quest'anno il terzo anniversario
è stata anche la prima giornata
nazionale della memoria e
dell'accoglienza della memoria e
dell'accoglienza perché non dimenticare
deve servire a far comprendere che
l'accoglienza oggi non è essere buoni
un dovere ed è uno strumento per
costruire la pace è un modo per aiutarli
a casa loro è la cosa più urgente che
possiamo fare della cosa che è nelle
nostre possibilità
non possiamo aspettare che a bruxelles
che si convincano i paesi europei a
mantenere gli impegni presi con
l'approvazione del piano di
ricollocamento che stabiliva un
principio quello dell'accoglienza
solidale quella della distribuzione equa
dei migranti e dei profughi che arrivano
sul nostro territorio
guardate avevano detto dobbiamo
ricollocarne in due anni 2015 e 2016 36
mila circa dall italia 66 mila dalla
grecia
sapete quanti ne abbiamo ricollocati
dall italia
1260 sapete quanti ce ne hanno
restituiti indietro più di 1500 cioè noi
abbiamo oggi 300 persone in più di
quelle che sono sbarcate sul nostro
territorio perché l'europa quella ricca
quella potente quella che decide
considera questi migranti economici non
aventi diritto ad alcuna forma di
protezione umanitaria
non solo ma secondo il regolamento di
dublino che disciplina il diritto
d'asilo e in europa è il paese di primo
arrivo che si deve prendere che deve
prendere in carico le persone salvate
quindi tutte le persone che arrivano dal
continente africano ma anche quelle che
arrivano dalla libia provenienti
provenendo dal medio oriente dovrebbero
rimanere in italia e per rendere tutto
ciò ancora più effettivo alzano i muri
lungo la lungo la frontiera dei balcani
ma un'altra cosa che dobbiamo smentire
sono i numeri dal 1991 ad oggi la
guardia costiera italiana che voglio
salutare e ringraziare perché fa un
lavoro enorme al rischio della stessa
vita degli uomini che si buttano in
acqua a tirare su bambini donne incinte
hanno salvato quasi circa più o meno 700
mila persone un po meno della metà sono
passati tutti da lampedusa un po più
della metà sono sbarcati dal 2014
ad oggi perché è il 2014 che segna la
crescita di questi numeri in realtà sono
20 anni che sentiamo le gli annunci del
della catastrofe della invasione da
parte di milioni di persone che
dovrebbero arrivare dall africa
in realtà i numeri sono questi mentre
soltanto nel 2015 quasi due milioni sono
entrati dai balcani
poi ci meravigliamo di questo ma se in
libia in siria non finisce la guerra
come vogliamo che ci siano milioni di
siriani che vivono nel fango e che hanno
visto per essere nel fango i loro
bambini vogliono portarli a scuola
vogliono avere una vita prima o poi
dovevano varcare questo maledetto
confine
mi sembra che rispetto alla infantilismo
all'egoismo dimostrato in questo momento
dall'europa
mi sembra adesso lampedusa un gigante in
realtà ce ne stiamo rendendo conto
adesso perché quello che abbiamo fatto
tutti i giorni è stato quello che
ciascuno di noi desidererebbe vorrebbe
che si facesse per i propri figli se
fossero dispersi per il mondo ma
un'altra cosa
e chiudo la cosa più terribile alla
quale non dobbiamo rassegnarci che non
dobbiamo smettere di denunciare e quella
che la chiusura dei confini
il regolamento di dublino
l'impossibilità di entrare in europa per
nessuna ragione nel per chiedere asilo
né per chiedere lavoro determina non
solo sofferenza determina morte dal 2013
da quel maledetto 3 ottobre 2013 con le
366 bar mostrate al mondo di fronte alle
quali si sono inginocchiati il
presidente della commissione europea
dicendo mai più morti
ebbene sono 11mila e 500 i morti in
questi 33 anni pensate quanti se ne sono
stati in questi 20 anni sepolti nel
silenzio senza essere stati visti o
avvistati dicono sono di più i morti
perché c'è stato mare nostrum perché i
soccorsi si fanno troppo vicino alla
libia
no sono di più i morti perché ne vediamo
di più ne contiamo di più quando non
c'era mare nostrum non c'era il
dispiegamento delle navi a sud di
lampedusa
loro morivano senza essere visti i
naufragi vengono raccontati solo dai
sopravvissuti
se non ci sono sopravvissuti nessuno
saprà mai dei naufragi
ecco la cosa a cui io mi sono ribellata
nel momento in cui sono diventata
sindaco mi sono liberata due cose 1
accettare la morte di queste persone
come un deterrente a non farli venire
considerare queste persone morte come
persone superflue di cui possiamo fare a
meno di cui abbiamo deciso di fare a
meno
non sopportavo l'idea che non avessero
un nome non avessero che le loro madri i
loro figli dai loro mogli le loro
sorelle i loro fratelli non potessero
piangere su quei corpi e non sopportavo
che questo dolore che questo lutto
dovesse pesare solo su lampedusa che
fino al 2013 è stata l'unica porta
d'ingresso in europa di seri de luca a
lampedusa però non è la porta di
servizio dell'europa oggi l'ambasciata
del mediterraneo ci siamo fatti
portavoce anche inaugurando quest'anno
il museo del dialogo e della fiducia
esponendo l'amorino dormiente di
caravaggio insieme agli oggetti dei
morti
gli orologi telefonini le foto le
lettere corano le big ai loro oggetti
mettendoli insieme per far riflettere
per far capire che si tratta di persone
di persone come noi che soffrono come
noi che non sono andate via dalla loro
terra con l'idea di invadere la nostra
loro si sono radicati dalla loro terra
lo fanno con sofferenza lo fanno con
dolore e li lasciano casa famiglia amori
affetti
e hanno una grande forza però quella che
noi in questo momento non stiamo
dimostrando verso di loro soprattutto
questa paura questa egoismo dilagante
questa xenofobia fa male anche ai
territori come noi a lampedusa alle
lampedusa del mediterraneo ai territori
di frontiera che pagano il prezzo di
queste politiche di chiusura lampedusa
oggi dimostra che la logica emergenziale
che produce degrado danni
destabilizzazione sociale della vita
amministrativa danni economici perché
lampedusa vive di turismo
noi l'abbiamo sconfitta l'abbiamo
sconfitta realizzando una grande
sinergia con il ministero con tutte le
forze preposte al soccorso alla prima
accoglienza oggi lampedusa offre un
modello di come si soccorrono le persone
di come vengono accolte in banchina di
come vengono curate e guardate che oggi
a lampedusa arrivano veramente le
persone più bisognose di cure ustionati
donne incinte con aborti o neonati
appena partoriti lampedusa ha dimostrato
che si può fare e se siamo stati in
grado di farlo noi che siamo così
piccoli lo possono fare tutti lo devono
fare tutti
non solo ma quest'anno la ragione di
maggiore fierezza mia e della mia
comunità è che abbiamo dimostrato con i
numeri che di accoglienza non si muore
noi quest'anno abbiamo fatto il 30 per
cento in più di presenze turistiche
perché abbiamo presentato l'isola sicura
serena un'isola che unisce alla bellezza
straordinaria perché guardate che i
confini la frontiera che si devono
militarizzare quelli che devono
diventare come call è come ventimiglia
come lampedusa era stata fino al 2011
sono in realtà i luoghi più belli del
mediterraneo
abbiamo dimostrato di saper unire alla
bellezza straordinaria del mare del
paesaggio la bellezza dell'accoglienza
accogliere è bello si può si deve fare
grazie